have Muslims been misreading
misinterpreting and misunderstanding the
Quran for nearly 14
centuries let's find out Jesus death by
crucifixion is regarded by historians
and New Testament Scholars as one of the
best established facts of the ancient
world Jesus death isn't simply a point
of Christian doctrine it's a historical
fact as even non-Christian Scholars are
happy to admit atheists new test scholar
G ludeman declares that Jesus death as a
consequence of crucifixion is
indisputable John Dominic crosson of the
infamous Jesus seminar says that there
is not the slightest doubt about the
fact of Jesus crucifixion under Pontius
Pilate Marcus Borg another member of the
Jesus seminar says that Jesus execution
is the most certain fact about the
historical Jesus Jewish scholar Pinkus
Leed affirmed that Jesus death by
crucifixion is historically certain
according to Paula Frederickson a
convert to Judaism the single most solid
fact about Jesus life is his death he
was executed by the Roman prefect pilate
on or around Passover in the manner Rome
reserved particularly for political
insurrectionists namely
crucifixion and Bart Man maintains one
of the most certain facts of history is
that Jesus was crucified on orders of
the Roman prefect of Judea Pontius
Pilate notice these non-Christian
Scholars aren't simply saying that we
have some evidence that Jesus died by
crucifixion they're saying that it's
indisputable that it's historically
certain that it's one of the most
certain facts of History we can only
conclude that any worldview that denies
Jesus death by crucifixion is simply out
of touch with reality yes I'm talking to
you too Jesus myther so that's what we
find when we consider Jesus crucifixion
from a purely historical perspective
from a Christian perspective Jesus death
on the cross isn't merely another
historical fact there are theological
implications the death of Jesus is
foundational to Christianity it was part
of a divine plan Jesus said things like
for even the son of man did not come to
be served but to serve and to give his
life as a ransom for many Mark
10:45 and the son of man is to be
delivered into the hands of men and they
will kill him and when he has been
killed he will rise 3 Days Later Mark
9:31 and the hour has come for the son
of man to be glorified very truly I tell
you unless a kernel of wheat falls to
the ground and dies it remains only a
Single Seed but but if it dies it
produces many seeds John 12:23 to
24 Jesus also warned his followers that
false prophets were coming now if Jesus
death is really as important as he makes
it sound do you think his death might be
something a false prophet is going to
deny or
distort so when Muhammad comes along and
says I have received a revelation and my
Revelation tells me that Jesus never
died there can be only one answer to
that we've been expecting you Muhammad
because Jesus warned us about you if
someone claims to speak for God and he
denies the crucifixion of Jesus he might
as well get a tattoo across his forehead
that says hi I'm a false prophet don't
believe anything I say
ever why would our Muslim friends tell
us to believe in Muhammad while
simultaneously telling us that he Bears
one of the shest signs of a false
prophet well our Muslim friends have
been forced into this position by the
Quran or so they think and the entire
problem comes from just one verse of the
Quran Surah 4 verse 157 let's read it
that they said in boast they here are a
group of Jews that they said in boast we
killed Christ Jesus the son of Mary the
Apostle of God but they killed him not
nor crucified him but so it was made to
appear to them and those who differ
therein are full of doubts with no
certain knowledge but only conjecture to
follow for of assurity they killed him
not and the next verse declares nay God
raised him up unto himself and God is
exalted in power
wise so according to the Quran some Jews
were boasting about killing Jesus the
Christ the Messiah the Apostle of God
Allah corrects them and says that they
didn't kill him or crucify him it only
appeared to them that they had killed
him and crucified him now what does the
Quran mean when it says that the Jews
didn't kill or crucify Jesus but that
they thought they did because it was
made to appear to them that they did the
Quran doesn't explain but the
traditional Muslim explanation goes was
something like this Jesus went around
telling people to believe in God and in
the Torah for some strange reason this
upset the Jews so much that they decided
to kill him but God had a plan God took
Jesus out of this world into heaven and
miraculously disguised someone else to
make him look like Jesus and it was this
other person who was crucified but God
made everyone think that it was Jesus
this is called substitution Theory the
the theory that Jesus was replaced by a
substitute there are numerous problems
with substitution Theory let's consider
four first substitution Theory portrays
Allah as a cosmic trickster more like
Loki than like the god of the Bible if
Jesus didn't actually die but Allah made
people think that Jesus died the real
reason billions of people are now
convinced that Jesus died is that Allah
did an outstanding job tricking every
notice according to the traditional
Muslim explanation you can't trust your
senses even if you see someone die with
your own eyes Allah might be tricking
you and once you have an omnipotent
deceiver running the universe how do you
know what to believe how can you tell
when the omnipotent deceiver you believe
in is tricking you or not tricking you
oh because our Prophet says how do you
know that the omnipotent deceiver you
believe in isn't tricking you through
your Prophet second the Islamic view
portrays Jesus as a total failure the
Jesus of the Quran spent years preaching
Islam only to have his life's work
sabotaged by Allah Who tricked the world
into believing that Jesus died by
crucifixion ultimately giving rise to
Christianity according to the Quran
Jesus followers were devout Muslims but
they must have disappeared rather
quickly without so much as a whimper
because have no records that any Muslim
followers of Jesus even existed so the
Islamic Jesus couldn't win a single
lasting Muslim convert and he
accomplished absolutely nothing of any
lasting
significance we respect Jesus how by
believing that your God sabotaged his
life's
work third Surah 61:4 of the Quran
claims that Allah aided the true
followers of Jesus until they became a
uppermost over those who rejected Jesus
but the followers of Jesus who became
uppermost over those who opposed Jesus
were Christians who proclaimed Jesus
death and Resurrection see the problem
Allah says he helped the true followers
until they became uppermost the
followers who became uppermost believed
in Jesus death and
Resurrection our Muslim friends tell us
that Jesus didn't die and that he didn't
rise from the dead so according to our
Muslim friends Allah aided the wrong
people fourth Surah 7 verse 157 of the
Quran says that Christians were still
reading the gospel during the time of
Muhammad and Surah 5: 47 of the Quran
commands Christians to judge by the
gospel since we know that the gospel
read by Christians in the 7th Century
proclaimed Jesus death by crucifixion
Muslims are contradicting the Quran when
they say that Jesus didn't die by
crucifixion see the problem Allah
affirms the gospel the gospel that
Christians had in the 7th Century which
is the gospel that we still have the
gospel that we have tells us over and
over again like a beating drum that
Jesus died on the cross so how can we
believe the Quran when the Quran orders
us to judge by scriptures that
contradict the Quran our Muslim friends
think they can avoid this problem by
saying that the gospel was corrupted but
notice if the gospel was corrupted then
Allah was ordering Christians to judge
by a corrupt book and not only does
Allah order Christians to judge by a
corrupt book he's the one who corrupted
it according to our Muslim friends
according to our Muslim friends Jesus
never died by crucifixion we open the
gospel and we read about Jesus dying by
crucifixion where did people get the
idea that Jesus died by
crucifixion from Allah Who tricked
people into believing that Jesus died by
crucifixion so if the gospel was
corrupted who corrupted
it according to our Muslim Friends The
Gospel was corrupted by the omnipotent
deceiver they
worship here we have to ask our Muslim
friends do you have any clue how insane
this sounds to anyone who actually
respects God and Jesus you're telling us
to believe in a God who tricks billions
of people for no reason and starts false
religions and undermines the work of his
own prophets and affirms the inspiration
and authority of scriptures that he
corrupted this sounds thoroughly demonic
why do you say
it again you say it because the Quran
has forced you into this
position or has it and that's the
question I really want to address here
does does the Quran really deny the
crucifixion of Jesus or are Muslims
misinterpreting the
Quran fun fact there has always been a
minority position in Islam that rejects
the traditional Muslim explanation of
Surah 4: 157 for many centuries there
have been Muslims who insist that the
Quran doesn't deny Jesus death by
crucifixion and as we're about to see
they may be right let's find out why
some Muslims are convinced that Jesus
died by crucifixion
and why they reject the traditional
Muslim explanation of 4157 to be clear
if you ignore everything else in the
Quran Surah 4: 157 does seem to deny the
crucifixion of Jesus they said in boast
we killed Christ Jesus the son of Mary
the Apostle of God but they didn't they
killed him not nor crucified him it was
made to appear to them that they killed
him but they
didn't that definitely sounds like it's
denying Jesus death and crucifixion and
that's why most Muslims believe that
Jesus didn't die and that he wasn't
crucified but watch what happens when we
dig a Little Deeper Surah 4: 157 is part
of a passage in which Allah is rebuking
a group of Jews the Quran says that the
Jews broke their Covenant they killed
prophets Allah put a seal on their
hearts because of their blasphemy they
falsely accused Mary they bragged about
Killing Jesus but every Jew will believe
in Jesus before he dies I.E they'll find
out the truth about Jesus when the angel
of death appears in context then Surah
4: 157 is not a response to the
Christian belief that Jesus died on the
cross it's not a response to the
historical claim that Jesus died on the
cross it's a response to a group of Jews
who were were saying we don't have to
believe in Jesus because we killed him
simply reading the context opens the
door for some alternative
interpretations for instance is 4157
saying that Jesus never died and was
never crucified or is it saying that
even though this group of Jews thought
they had exposed Jesus as a false
Messiah by crucifying him they didn't
really kill him they didn't really
crucify him meaning to kill someone by
crucifixion because Allah raised him
up you think you don't have to believe
in Jesus because you killed him you
didn't really kill him because Allah
raised him up what does it was made to
appear to them mean does it mean that
Allah took another person and
miraculously disguised him to make him
look like Jesus so that people thought
they were crucifying Jesus even though
they were crucifying someone else that's
the traditional view but that's not what
the verse actually says could it simply
mean that they thought they had exposed
Jesus by killing him but that it only
appeared to them that way because Allah
Vindicated him by raising him from the
dead so just by examining the
surrounding context we can see why some
Muslims have interpreted this verse
differently but there are more
challenges to the traditional Muslim
explanation in other parts of the Quran
in Surah
19:33 Jesus is speaking miraculously as
a baby and he says so peace is on me the
day I was born the day that I die and
the day that I shall be raised up to
life again notice the pattern the day I
was born the day that I die the day that
I shall be raised up birth death
Resurrection what happened to Jesus in
surar for verse 158 God raised him up
unto himself
According To Jesus in the Quran
1933 what was supposed to happen to him
before he was raised he was supposed to
die so if Jesus was raised in
4158 why would Muslims say that he
didn't die in
4157 are they saying that Jesus was
wrong in 1933 are they saying that Jesus
was a false prophet the point here is
that Islamic baby Jesus described a
simple pattern he was born he would die
he would be raised our Muslim friends
present a much more complicated pattern
they say he was born then he was raised
without dying one day he will be lowered
back to Earth then he'll die then he'll
be raised
again that doesn't sound anything like
what Jesus said in
1933 and it doesn't sound anything like
what Allah says in Surah 3:5 5 where
Allah speaks to Jesus during his
ministry and tells him what's about to
happen behold God said oh Jesus I will
take thee and raise thee to myself and
clear thee of the falsehoods of those
who blaspheme I will make those who
follow thee Superior to those who reject
Faith to the day of Resurrection then
shall ye all return unto me and I will
judge between you of the matters wherein
ye
dispute what a ridiculous translation
yusf Ali translates this as I will take
thee and raise thee to
myself I will take thee the Arabic here
is
mut most Muslim translators do what yusf
Ali did they translate this as I will
take you or I will gather you but that's
just not what mutfa means Surah 3: 55
doesn't say that Allah will take Jesus
away without Jesus dying it says that
Allah will cause Jesus to Die the kind
of taking that Allah says he's about to
do is taking away a person's soul this
usually refers to causing death Islam
also teaches that when a person goes to
sleep Allah takes away his soul but then
returns it when he wakes up so when the
context is something about going to bed
Allah taking away your soul can refer to
to Allah causing you to fall asleep but
when there's nothing about going to bed
in context taking your soul means taking
your soul from your body and causing you
to
die most Orthodox Muslims mistranslate
355 because they know it contradicts
their interpretation of
4157 they killed him not nor crucified
him so they decide based on 4157 that
Jesus never died then they go to 355 for
Allah says I will cause you to die and
they have to mistranslate it as I will
take you or I will gather you but look
at three translations from non-orthodox
Muslims here's the Sher Ali translation
Allah says oh Jesus I will cause thee to
die a natural death and will raise thee
to myself and the Khalifa translation oh
Jesus I am terminating your life raising
you to me and the Muhammad Assad
translation oh Jesus verily I shall
cause thee to die and shall exalt thee
unto
me what about non-muslim translations
here's the Palmer translation oh Jesus I
will make thee die and take thee up
again to me and the Rodwell translation
oh Jesus verily I will cause thee to die
and will take thee up to myself and and
the s translation oh Jesus verily I will
cause thee to die and I will take thee
up unto me are you seeing a pattern from
translators who aren't deliberately
mistranslating this verse to avoid
contradicting their interpretation of
4157 everyone seems to understand that
it means Allah is going to cause Jesus
to die but don't take my word for it you
can perform a little experiment from the
comfort of your own home home look up
Surah 3:55 on a Quran site that has the
Arabic copy the Arabic and paste it into
a translator like Google translate
here's what you'll get Google Allah says
oh Jesus I will cause you to die and I
will raise you to me even Google Allah
admits that this is saying Allah would
cause Jesus to die why do non-orthodox
Muslims and non-muslims and and even
Google translate 355 as Allah telling
Jesus that he's going to cause him to
die because that's what the verse says
but again most Muslim translators won't
translate 355 accurately because they
think to themselves hm Surah 4: 157
clearly says that Jesus wasn't killed
and wasn't crucified so Jesus never died
therefore Surah
3:55 obviously can't be saying that
Jesus died we have to come up with a
different translation
they start with their interpretation of
4157 they didn't kill him nor did they
crucify him and they use that
interpretation to reinterpret 355 Allah
will cause Jesus to die and raise him
but notice they could do the exact
opposite they could say well in 355
Allah clearly said he was going to cause
Jesus to die so we should probably
rethink our interpretation of
4157 maybe it isn't saying that Jesus
never died to be clear
4157 they killed him not nor crucified
him if you read it completely on its own
does sound like it's denying Jesus death
just as 355 I shall cause thee to die if
you read it completely on its own sounds
like it's affirming Jesus death assuming
you want to avoid a contradiction you
have to reinterpret one of these verses
now when you're in this position when
you have two verses that seem to be
saying opposite things and you have to
reinterpret one of them you should ask
yourself what other reasons do I have
for interpreting verse such and such
this way or that way is there other
evidence to go on are there other
considerations that could tip the
balance in One Direction or the other
355 oh Jesus verily I shall cause thee
to die sounds like it's saying that
Jesus was about to die what reason
reasons do we have for reinterpreting
this and concluding that it's not
affirming Jesus death there's only one
reason the traditional Muslim
interpretation of 4157 they killed him
not nor did they crucify him that's the
only reason to reinterpret 355 there are
no other
reasons let's ask the same question
about
4157 4 1557 sounds like it's saying that
Jesus wasn't killed and wasn't crucified
what reasons do we have for
reinterpreting this and concluding that
it's not denying jesus' death here we
have all kinds of reasons for
reinterpreting this we've already seen
that in context 4157 isn't a response to
Christian beliefs about jesus' death
it's a response to a Jewish claim that
Jesus death had exposed him as a false
Messiah we've seen that in 355 Allah
says he's going to cause Jesus to die
many people would say that Surah 5 verse
117 also affirms Jesus death we've seen
that 1933 suggests that Jesus would be
born then die then be raised which
doesn't fit well with the standard
Muslim interpretation of
4157 we've also seen four theological
problems with the standard Muslim
interpretation of 4157 substitution
Theory portrays Allah as a cosmic
trickster who starts false religions for
no reason and corrupts the teachings of
his own Prophets The traditional Muslim
view portrays Jesus as a total failure
who spent years preaching but couldn't
win a single lasting convert the Quran
claims that Allah aided the true
followers of Jesus until they became
uppermost over those who rejected Jesus
and we know that the followers of Jesus
who became uppermost definitely believed
in his death by crucifixion and the
Quran affirms the inspiration
preservation and authority of Christian
scriptures that Clearly indisputably say
that Jesus died by crucifixion so we
have some very good reasons to
reinterpret suror verse 157 but we can
go even further because we can try to
figure out what Allah is actually saying
in
4157 Allah says they killed him not nor
crucified him if we keep digging and we
come up with a different way of
understanding 4157 a way that doesn't
conflict with history and Theology and
the rest of the Quran we should probably
go with this Al alternative
interpretation because everything else
we have to go on tells us that Jesus
died but what could Allah possibly mean
when he says they didn't kill him nor
did they crucify him I'll give you two
possibilities straight from the Quran
I'm not smuggling in my own views here
these come from the
Quran suppose right before we read Surah
4: 157 we read Surah 3 verse 169
think not of those who are slain in
God's way as dead nay they live finding
their sustenance in the presence of
their lord if someone dies for Allah
don't think of him as dead because he's
alive he's in the presence of
Allah so let's say you're a Muslim and
your friend Abdullah goes out to fight
the kufar and the kufar kill him then
the kufar come to you and say haha we
killed Abdullah we shot him with a bunch
of arrows and now he's
dead as a Muslim how are you supposed to
respond according to Sur 3 verse
169 when someone says Abdullah is dead
because we killed him you're supposed to
reply no he isn't and no you didn't
Abdullah is alive and safe with
Allah suppose you absorb what Allah says
in
3169 don't think of those who are slain
for Allah as dead because they're alive
and then you read 4 157 to 158 that they
said in boast we killed Christ Jesus the
son of Mary the Apostle of God but they
killed him not nor crucified him but so
it was made to appear to them and those
who differ therein are full of doubts
with no certain knowledge but only
conjecture to follow for of assurity
they killed him not nay God raised him
up unto himself and God is exalted in
power
wise if you read 4157 to 158 right after
reading
3169 would you conclude that the only
possible interpretation of 4157 is that
Allah miraculously disguised some other
person and made this other person look
like Jesus and had this other person die
in Jesus place no because there's a much
much simpler interpretation based on
what Allah says in three 3 169 it makes
perfect sense to interpret 4 157 to 158
as Allah saying it may have appeared to
this group of Jews as if they killed
Jesus it may have appeared to them as if
they crucified Jesus but Jesus is Alive
and safe with Allah Allah raised him up
so they didn't really do what they
thought they did much
simpler but I said I was going to give
two possible ways to interpret 4157 from
the Quran here's the other possibility
suppose right before you read Surah 4:
157 you read Surah 8 verse
17 this is about the Battle of bad
Muslims were outnumbered but they
defeated the meccans at one point
Muhammad threw a handful of dust at the
meccans after the battle some of the
Muslims were boasting about killing the
kufar look at what Allah says to them it
is not ye who slew them it was God
when thou thest a handful of dust it was
not thy act but God's in order that he
might test the Believers by a gracious
trial from himself for God Is He Who
heareth and knoweth all things the yusf
AL here is a bit awkwardly worded let's
read the heli Khan you killed them not
but Allah killed them and you Muhammad
threw not when you did throw but Allah
threw that he might test the Believers
by a fair trial from him verily Allah is
all hearer all knower picture this
Muhammad and his companions are totally
outnumbered but they defeat the
meccans Muhammad's companions start
boasting look at all the unbelievers we
killed and then Allah reveals you didn't
kill them I did Muhammad didn't throw
that dust I did it may have appeared to
you as if you were doing these things
but you were all mere instruments in my
hand I used you to accomplish my goals
so stop boasting you didn't do these
things I did these things through you
it's a little strange to think that way
about a battle but that's exactly how
Allah commands Muslims to think about
their battles you run out into battle to
fight the kufar you kill five of the
kufar you run back and say I killed five
kufar and Allah says no you didn't you
didn't kill them you didn't stab them
with your sword you didn't shoot them
with your bow you didn't do any of that
it appeared to you that way but in
reality I was the one who was doing it I
was accomplishing my purposes through
you suppose you read that and you get
your mind around what Allah is saying in
87 when you do certain things you're not
really doing them and then you read 4
157 to
158 that they said in boast we killed
Christ Jesus the son of Mary the Apostle
of God but they killed him not nor
crucified him but so it was made to
appear to them and those who differ
therein are full of doubts with no
certain knowledge but only conjecture to
follow for of assurity they killed him
not nay God raised him up unto himself
and God is exalted in power
wise if you read 4 157 to 158 after
reading 817 are you going to think that
this is a la declaring no you didn't
kill Jesus you didn't crucify him you
only think you did because I took
another person and I miraculously
changed his appearance to make him look
like Jesus and it was this other person
that you
crucified is that how you would
interpret this verse or would you go
with the the much simpler
interpretation you think you killed
Jesus you think you crucified
Jesus you didn't do anything to Jesus
that I didn't want to happen you didn't
cause Jesus to die I caused Jesus to
die what did Allah say in
355 Allah said to Jesus during Jesus
Earthly Ministry oh Jesus verily I will
call cuse thee to die and will take thee
up to
myself who's really causing Jesus to die
according to
Allah are the Jews causing Jesus to die
no are the Romans causing Jesus to die
no who's causing Jesus to die
Allah so if Allah told Jesus Jesus I'm
going to cause you to die then then I'm
going to raise you up and some Jews
talking to Muhammad say why should we
believe in Jesus when we killed him how
should Allah
respond he should respond by saying you
may think you killed Jesus it may have
appeared to you that you exposed him as
a false Messiah but in reality this was
all part of my plan this was something I
was doing I told Jesus this was going to
happen I told him I was going to cause
him to die and I completely Vindicated
him by raising him and that's exactly
what Allah sounds like he's saying in 4
157 to 158 if we read the passage after
reading
87 you killed them not but Allah killed
them so putting all of this together
there is one count him one Quran verse
that sounds like it's saying Jesus did
didn't die there are other Quran verses
that sound like they're saying Jesus did
die most Muslim Scholars over the
centuries have decided to stick with
their interpretation of the one verse
that sounds like it's saying Jesus
didn't die and they use their
interpretation of that one verse to
reinterpret other Quran verses and to
reject the consensus of historians and
to accuse Allah of deceiving billions of
people and undermining the work of his
own prophet and corrupting his own reev
ations and helping the wrong group
become uppermost and starting the
world's largest false religion
Christianity according to
Muslims we've got two main hypotheses
here one Jesus died by crucifixion two
Allah tricked people into believing that
Jesus died by
crucifixion if we were to put all of the
evidence and all of the different
considerations that favor one hypothesis
over the other into a balance one side
basically drops to the floor the
hypothesis that Jesus died by
crucifixion is massively stronger than
the hypothesis that Allah tricked people
into believing that Jesus died by
crucifixion and yet you can put all of
this information and much more in front
of the average Muslim and ask him did
Jesus die and he'll reply with complete
confidence no Jesus didn't die it says
right there in Surah 4 verse 157 they
killed him not nor crucified him so case
closed the amazing thing about this is
that Muslims are quite happy to
reinterpret just about any other verse
in the Quran we ask our Muslim friends
what does Allah mean when he says fight
those who believe not in God nor the
last day oh he means only fight and
self-defense we ask what does Allah mean
when he says that Christians and Jews
have no ground to stand upon unless we
stand fast by the Torah tah and the
gospel oh he means that the Torah and
the gospel have been corrupted so
everyone just needs to go to the
Quran apparently it's quite common for
Allah to sound like he's saying one
thing even though he's actually saying
something completely
different The Only Exception is 4157
there Allah means exactly what he sounds
like he means even though the context
and other Quran verses and history and
theology give us a lot of very very good
reasons to think that Allah means
something different so why are most
Muslims obsessed with substitution
Theory because they've been conditioned
to always go along with whatever their
shakes and imams say and their shakes
and imams don't want to admit that Jesus
died and rose from the dead because
believing in jesus' death and
Resurrection might bring Muslims a
little too close to
Christianity can't have that so they
just keep propagating substitution
Theory they keep ignoring the context
they keep ignoring other Quran verses
they keep rejecting history they keep
rejecting
scholarship but that raises an important
final question for Muslims my Muslim
friends is Islam the religion of
submission to
Allah or is it the religion of
submission to your shakes and imams
if Islam is the religion of submission
to Allah now would be a really good time
to take a closer look at what Allah says
so that you don't falsely accuse him of
saying things that he didn't say and of
doing things that he didn't
do and if your shakes and imams tell you
something different if they tell you to
submit to them and not to Allah you
should probably find some better shakes
and
imams but if you still think you can can
trust them be sure to watch my video
what the Quran really says about the
gospel where I go through every single
verse in the entire Quran that so much
as mentions the gospel and oddly enough
I can't find one word about the gospel
being corrupted in fact Allah says the
exact opposite of what your shakes and
imams
say how can you trust them when they lie
to
you
[Music]